a modern take on resigning but mohammad
javad zarif
Instagram post was vague he offered an
apology for all the shortcomings and
flaws but gave no reason for his
departure all of this was written on a
drawing of Fatima the Prophet Muhammad's
daughter whose birth was being
commemorated on Monday in Tehran a
foreign ministry spokesperson quickly
confirmed the news but also gave no
reason it's an abrupt end to more than
five and a half years as Iranian Foreign
Minister Zarif had a prominent role in
negotiating the landmark 2015 nuclear
agreement between Iran and major
international powers in exchange for
limiting nuclear activities Tehran had
economic sanctions lifted but Zarif has
been under pressure since the United
States withdrew from the pact he
expressed his frustration at Washington
at the Munich Security Conference
earlier this month we have long been the
target of an unhealthy fixation let's
say an obsession which continues to this
very day the demonization of my country
has been a convenient cross for seven
consecutive American presidents to bear
Sabbath's resignation could play into
the hands of hardliners in Iran they
have been growing more vocal about their
anger towards the country's moderate
president Hassan rouhani for the
weakening state of the Iranian economy
Mohammad Javad Zarif has been one of
rouhani's main allies his departure
could weaken the president's position
and let's get more now I am joined by
Tehran based political analyst Amnon
Tabata by he is the CEO of the Center
for Applied Research in partnership with
the orient welcome to you and I'd like
to begin by asking you what do you think
is behind this resignation it has been
quite open in the media here in Tehran
that it had a lot to do with the meeting
of Syrian President Bashar Assad
yesterday and that the foreign ministry
and more important
the Foreign Minister was not included in
that meeting there is a lot of debate
about why that is and it is yet to be to
be seen whether it was a mistake whether
there was a lack of coordination whether
it was he was deliberately sidelined by
President rouhani or what was really
behind it but that has been the the key
element here but you know if we look at
the political side of things I mean
Zarif he's he's seen as a as a moderate
relatively speaking does this
resignation do you think it now weakens
the position of the also moderate
president rouhani now in general we have
to say that the the situation in Iran
not only internally but primarily in
international politics has has certainly
weakened them the moderate direction of
this country wanted to take that has
this has to do with the frustration
about where the nuclear deal has been
going and that this moderates political
current which was led by rouhani and
Zarif certainly is under tremendous
pressure and the resignation if it is
accepted if it goes through is certainly
weakening this political group in Iran
so if you had to just you know perhaps
make a projection here where do you see
the political current now going because
I mean we have the u.s. upholding
sanctions on Tehran do you think that we
could potentially see now a new hawkish
foreign minister with a tougher
anti-american posture coming in here I
mean in your report we just saw javad
zarif speaking at the immunised Munich
Security Conference he he helped quite
hawkish positions on the US so in fact
even with moderate figures like Hassan
rouhani and javad zarif
the political sentiments here in Tehran
are such that you can no longer afford
solely banking on outreach with the West
and particularly with the US there has
to be a harsh rhetoric position and
regardless of whether that if stays or
is replaced by someone else we have to
expect more rich harsher rhetoric
towards the US for sure
advantage about to by joining us with
the very latest on the situation there
in Iran thank you so much
you